my big thing is this always look at the  person giving the advice that's my  advice show me who's giving you the  other advice I'm very fascinated by this  people are always like Gary but this  person told me to do this and I'm like  what the [ __ ] is that person doing and  first of all [ __ ] my advice do you  forget about garyvee or Sally [ __ ]  Thompson do you you want to talk about  [ __ ] supply chain from China today  post you want to [ __ ] write a  LinkedIn article today about real estate  post you want to [ __ ] film you on  Beijing air [ __ ] Landing post my dear  everybody here is overthinking at the  cost of doing and using perfectionism as  an excuse to not do the doing it's only  the doing